welcome to CBS this morning bianna is
off today a manhunt is underway for the
suspect we will begin with this the
suspect has been identified by police in
the shooting death of rapper and
neighborhood activists Nipsey Hussle los
angeles police say overnight the gunman
is 29 year old Eric Holder the suspects
identity was released him in a chaotic
memorial for the grammy-nominated artist
last night 19 people were hurt after
witnesses say a fight broke out the
sound of shattered glass apparently led
to a stampede hundreds of people had
gathered outside hustle' store where he
was gunned down Sunday well Jamie yuccas
is there at Los Angeles Police
Headquarters Jamie good morning good
morning police accuse holder of shooting
Nipsey Hussle and two other men who
survived as many as 400 people showed up
Monday night to pay their respects at
the shooting scene when once again panic
erupted for most of Monday a vigil for
rapper and community leader Nipsey
Hussle had been peaceful but shortly
after 8 p.m.
something caused the crowd to panic
traditional units lost any pressure most
of the 19 people injured were caught up
in the stampede that followed
many were treated at the scene two
patients are in critical condition
one hit by a car and another with what
officials are calling a penetrating
traumatic injury police say some in the
crowd resisted orders to disperse while
we were clearing the area there were
rocks and bottles being thrown at police
officers we have at least one officer
that was injured tonight back to back we
put a curfew on people at the vigil
honored Nipsey Hussle as more than a
grammy-nominated musician but also for
the good he did for his South Los
Angeles neighborhood community leaders
and fans said at memorials outside his
clothing store where he was gunned down
Sunday I'm heartbroken he had a very
positive message and just shocked in
disbelief he lost a legend and a pillar
of this community who loved us who cared
for us surveillance video shows the
moments leading up to Nipsey Hussle
murder on Sunday a man whom police
believed to be Eric Holder approached
nipsey people scattered as shots are
fired and nipsey fell to the ground
police believed nipsey knew the shooter
this was not a chance encounter we don't
think that this was a sudden engagement
we want the community to turn nipsey's
murderer in because to us this a
snitching is not being held accountable
for your actions
police have not announced a motive in
Sunday night's shooting Nipsey Hussle
did admit to ties to gangs as a teenager
we should learn more here at the Los
Angeles Police Department during a press
conference later on this morning John
alright Jamie thank you